when I announced hey and the speakers at
this event will be President George Bush
silent because some people were not
wanting to see him some people were very
happy but it was 50 50. I said Kobe
everybody from town they lost their mind
so Kobe President Bush comes we we do
the event
there's 6 000 people there 6200 and we
have a great conversation in the back
and then afterwards he's doing photo op
with 100 people that qualify to do the
pictures and I'm standing there the
entire time because I just want to hear
what people are going to say and people
would say things like let me tell you I
saw you as this and when you were
president I thought you were this and I
thought you were that but the message
you gave today because he just opened up
he says let me tell you what I did I
used to do this I had a bad habit of
doing this I had a bad habit of doing
this
the way he spoke that day everybody fell
in love with the guy that day the way he
spoke President Bush so it's interesting
that you're saying how one day they love
you next day they hate you next day they
miss you the next day they hate you you
have to be patient because if you're
loved today take your time someone's
gonna hate you in about a couple months
and if they hate you today be patient
trust me there's love around the corner
as well this whole concept about how you
deal with love-hate relationship how did
you handle that as a player because
that's that's got to be something you
experienced well I played with two most
historic teams you know I consider
myself really lucky you know being
drafted by the Red Sox at the University
of Texas you know so I mean the Rangers
and Astros are following me so close to
Texas you know again I I got to go back
to when I was in high school I was the
third best pitcher on the team I had two
I I took classes early so I could
graduate at 17.
um but when there were two other guys
riding Lefty back in the 80s that threw
over 90 miles an hour which was you know
rare the scouts are coming to watch him
now we got in the playoffs a couple
times I was a better defensive end than
I was probably a pitcher first baseman
and uh really yeah I was six two I was
still you know baby fat you know I was
young Roger your hands are massive hands
yeah yeah I got my granddad
yeah is that a benefit for a pitcher or
is that for that split finger it is
yeah so the size of that ring but yeah
that's our national I'm wearing my
national championship ring more and I do
uh just because
um yeah it got start it really happened
for me at the University again
um you know jumping around I had three
wonderful coaches coming up you know I
lost my pops my high school coach
um great great coach better teacher of
the game and life lessons then I go and
I get to play for Wayne Graham one of
the winningest coaches in college
baseball turn the University of rice
program around
great coach better teacher to game
baseball lifer and um
he watched me grow and mature that your
pop over to Texas
play for the winningest coach at that
time uh Cliff Gustafson and um Gus the
same thing great coach uh better man and
teacher of what we are doing life
lessons my boys go to University of
Texas they play for their winningest
coach in baseball Augie guerrito who
since since passed Augie was Augie was
gave them some great life lessons
so
again that's where I came from I I was
the third best pitcher I tell the kids
nobody but I threw strikes and I had a
little Bugs Bunny curveball so when
those older guys everybody came to see
him they didn't went to bed they [__]
the bed coach would bring me in the game
because I threw strikes coach always
said after you know I got I I made it a
couple years in the big leagues he said
you know that kid I could bring him in
turn the lights out in the stadium he
could throw strikes
so then when I got to Texas we didn't
there was no baseball lifting stuff we
lifted with the football guys so my legs
got strong I grew two inches fastball
started jumping next thing you know I
mean the same reason why I went to Texas
on scholarship mom didn't have the money
so I was Paving my way and she wanted me
to stay in school when I got drafted
after my freshman year
um the Scout said you know if he didn't
sign right now he probably never get
another chance my mom basically told him
and I was in my room crying for two days
she's kicked the scout out of the house
said he's going to school I want him to
get his education
so
that's kind of how that's that's you
know that's kind of how my path you know
took place and then
um Boston drafted me I was like
Boston when I don't even know I don't
even sure where Boston was you know and
uh but my mom the history we love
history and
um uh
she wrote me a poem about Fenway Park
and then when I got to Fenway
um you know the green monster the the
best was when they called me up uh I
don't think cell phones are there this
is 83 and I was watching the game I
think Dennis Eckersley and Palmer were
pitching but they bring me in I get in
the cab and at the airport and I've got
my face in a paper and the guy stops
cabbie stops and this brick I see this
brick building in the cab because here
you go kid I go cabby I'm a professional
ball player I'm going to Fenway Park I
said this is a looks like a warehouse
I see the brick only you know he goes
this is Fenway Park kid get get your ass
out of my head and I and I get out and
the team meets me and they bring me up
the tunnel and the tunnel right you know
on first base side where you see the
green monster
and then to go you know there uh and
jump forward
playing as long as I did both the two
older boys and I had Devin I had a
little 10-year break and then the other
boys are in their 20s now
um they were able to see me play long
enough when the boys make a comma it's
like pops and you know you pitched right
where Lou Gehrig gave his Farewell speed
or you know they I played in the Bob
Hope turn up 20 years I had Yogi Bear as
my partner a couple times you know
having Yogi I mean the guy's got he's
got ten Rings was he funny as hell was
he oh yeah oh he played it up I told him
I said hey about third or fourth hole
all this media follows I want to get an
eight by ten of you and I I'm gonna I'm
gonna line my putt up I want you to
leaning over like you're reading it for
me but we're doing it seriously there
was it was funky and I kind of knew
which way it's going to break but I hear
we staged this photo
and people are everywhere and I out loud
I go Yogi what do you think which way
you know what which way this ball going
he goes
better you than me kid and he walked off
and it was a little yeah he was I always
told Yogi that uh the two catchers I
wish I would have thrown to were Yogi
and Johnny Bench and uh Yogi was why why
me I said because I see all the old
photos of you Yogi and you never could
squat down you you know I would get the
high strike for sure because you could
never squat so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you
[Music]